RACHEL: Identify limiting
patterns, beliefs, and habits.
Communicate more authentically
and powerfully.
And then, ignite purpose and
vision in anything you do,
including work.
So please join me in welcoming
Steve Sisgold.
Thank you.
STEVE SISGOLD: Thank you.
Thank
you, Rachel [APPLAUSE]
STEVE SISGOLD: I thought I
would start today off by
letting you know a little bit
about what we're going to do.
First of all-- everybody
can hear me?
It's all good?
OK, first of all, we're going to
do some self-reflection to
take a look at our own
awareness, our own--
just things that we're not
aware of sometimes.
We can be driving to work like
this, holding our wheel, and
have no idea because we're
thinking about what happened
at the breakfast table.
We're thinking about what's
going to happen later.
And then, we get to work.
And we say, ah, my shoulders
are tight.
And we have no idea.
I constantly am--
I also write quite a bit, as
Rachel said-- my book.
And sometimes, I'll be slumping
over my computer.
And I have no idea
I'm doing it.
And my sweetie will walk
by and say, you're in
slump-asanas, if
you know yoga.
And I'll go, oh, god, I didn't
even realize it.
So there's a lot of
self-awareness that's going to
help us have more energy
and feel better
throughout the day.
We're also going to look into
things like, what are some
beliefs that I might be carrying
in my body that could
impact performance,
my relationships?
And we're going to be looking at
just the whole idea of how
I communicate, what
my billboard--
I call your body your
billboard--
is perhaps communicating,
micro-messages.
We'll do a self-assessment.
And I'll teach you my rebuilding
technique.
And then, we'll have some
fun-- interactive.
So since my book is called
"What's Your Body Telling
You?," I thought I'd tell you
why I came up with that title
and how that came about.
First, it started with
the fact that I was
working with people.
I was in sales.
And I did really
well in sales.
I was the number 1 out
of 500 salespeople.
And that was exciting.
And at the same time,
I noticed something.
I noticed-- this is going
to sound strange.
But I noticed people weren't
breathing, literally.
I'd say, wow, that person's
making a presentation.
[GASP]
STEVE SISGOLD: They're holding
their breath the whole time.
So I became curious about that,
why we hold our breath,
why we're not breathing.
And then, secondly, I noticed,
especially when I was coaching
and training, that people would
say one thing, and their
body would be saying
something else.
That incongruence was giving
an incongruent message.
And I noticed that for
myself and others.
When what I said and my body
said the same thing, I got a
better response.
Anybody relate to that?
Because you're talking
to somebody, and they
say, how you doing?
Oh, I'm doing great.
Oh, OK, doesn't look like it.
So we do that all day long.
It's amazing how many
micro-messages
we're sending out daily.
So I just became really
curious about it.
And I started studying somatic
intelligence, which is
basically "soma" is Greek
for the body.
I started learning about, what
does that really mean?
And then, I got into more
depth of beliefs.
And I'll go into that today.
I wanted to share a short story
with you where I believe
it started, where I started
listening to my body more and
listening to those instincts.
First of all, do you ever have
a gut instinct, but you
don't follow it?
It happens, right?
Do you ever have an instinct
like you want to say
something, but you, for some
reason or another [GASPS]
you hold it back?
Yeah, that's what we do.
And there's a lot of
reasons for that.
And I'll cover those today.
But for me, it really started
when I was a young boy sitting
at my daily dinner table.
And my father came
home one night.
And when he came home, usually,
he would come home
kind of like this.
If you watch animals-- if you
watch a bird when they're
happy, they're like this.
If you watch a bird after an oil
spill, they're like this.
It's a very distinct
message, right?
There's even been studies
with blind people that
when they're excited--
yeah!
They jump up, just like
a football player
or any one of us.
It's an instinct to be open.
But often, we'll
be contracted.
And we'll go inward.
So my dad often came home
from work like this.
But one day, he came
home like this.
And I was like, wow,
what's going on?
What's going on with Dad?
So I said, Dad, what's up?
And he said something I had
never heard before.
And I don't know if you
have ever heard
this from your parents.
My dad said, I have a dream.
I'm like, whoa.
Have you ever--
I never heard my parents
say, I have a dream.
My dad, said, hey,
I have a dream.
I was like, wow,
that's amazing.
So he started to tell us his
dream at the dinner table.
He was up.
I always look at that energy,
that ascending--
I'm going to write a book!
Oh, there's no need
for another book.
And then, we drop down.
I watched that.
My dad said, I have a dream.
I saw a little food market.
I'm tired of working
as a manager.
I want to buy my own store.
And then, he looked
to the right.
And there was my mom.
And my mom was like,
I don't think so.
We've got two kids growing up.
We need a check.
And my dad went like
this to this.
And I watched it.
He was totally self-defeated.
How many times have you had an
idea, and you went and told
one person, and they didn't like
it, and you just dropped
down and forgot about it?
Is there anybody who
can relate to that?
Absolutely.
I don't know what happened.
But I watched my dad's
dream go away.
Here I am.
I was like eight years
old, if that.
And I felt something in my body,
which I kept trying to
push down because I didn't want
to have my mom upset.
And I'm just a little kid.
But something happened
that kind of
surged through my body.
And I couldn't hold it back.
And I just wound up screaming at
the dinner table, why can't
Daddy have his dream?
And I looked at my mom.
And she was-- my sister looked
at me like, man, you're crazy.
And I saw my dad go back
up a little bit.
And my mom said, well,
jeesh, I guess we
could go look at it.
So they went next-door.
And they looked at this
little food market.
And they bought it.
And three days later--
no kidding--
there was a Maryland
food strike.
Every Giant, Safeway,
A&P closed.
And we had lines, and
lines, and lines
around my dad's store.
Of course, my dad did it.
It was his dream.
And he executed the business.
But it always reminded me, like,
what might have happened
if I didn't follow what
I felt in my body?
What didn't happen-- what
would've happened if I didn't
let that instinct out?
And you have my book.
So you'll read lots of stories
in there around people,
including myself, I've worked
with where when we followed
that instinct, when we listened
to our gut, when we
listened to our whole body,
not just our mind,
the result we got.
So just take a moment.
I call it the "loop of
awareness." Already, from what
I've said, just think in terms
of, huh, how often do I keep
my instincts in?
How often does my body say,
don't do that, but I do it
anyway to please people?
How often do I feel something,
but I'm not really
listening to it?
And in my work, I have
found that--
I know this is going to
sound funny to you.
But I tell people, when I go out
and talk, I say, it's your
personal Google.
I use that.
I say, your body's like
your personal Google.
You can get information.
It's the library
of your flesh.
Your body was there
from day one.
Your body will explain to you,
if you take the time and
listen, oh, that's why I'm
afraid to say that.
That's why I cringe up when
I hear something.
And we'll be doing exercises
around that today.
So you'll have an experience
with it, OK?
So the first thing, we've got
a PowerPoint back here.
I'm going to walk to it.
And if you can't see, let me
know, because of the light.
But basically, what I went
through is that we're going to
stay present, engage.
We're going to learn how to
lower our stress, improve our
skills, and change nonproductive
beliefs.
And I just wanted to show you,
just because sometimes it's
important to people, I had this
rebooting technique I'm
going to teach you today.
I took it into a medical
clinic where three MD's
requested it.
And they hooked people
up with all of
these wires and machines.
And they found that
rebooting--
now, you know, when a computer
goes down, when there's a
problem, what do we do?
We reboot.
But often, as humans,
we don't reboot.
So I've been working in
corporations, and as Rachel
said, the workplace, where
I've been helping people
reboot twice a day.
And they have more energy at
the end of the day, more
creative ideas.
And then, with this study,
basically, it showed that
there was a 55% reduction
in stress.
We can all have less stress.
And that the autonomic nervous
system changed,
and the heart changed.
And here's why.
You may know this.
But I'm going to just go through
the sympathetic and
the parasympathetic.
Right now, take a moment, just
where you're sitting, and just
ask yourself, with no judgment,
just observing, are
you breathing from down here
in your lower diaphragm?
Or are you breathing up here?
Or are you basically holding
your breath a lot?
No judgment, just notice,
just notice.
It's the first of what I call
the integrative conversation
between the mind and the body.
[BREATHES IN DEEPLY]
STEVE SISGOLD: I observe
my breath several
times during the day.
I don't walk around thinking
about it a lot.
But just as I'm driving, I'm
leaving here to pick up some
printing, I'll be
driving just--
[BREATHES IN DEEPLY]
STEVE SISGOLD: --going
down in my belly and
noticing I'm breathing.
And here's why.
We were made, biologically, that
if we're in a jungle, and
there's a tiger chasing us, we
can get up that tree very
quickly because we go into our
sympathetic nervous system,
which is breathing up here.
[SHALLOW GASPS]
STEVE SISGOLD: And as a result,
here's what happens.
Digestive system starts to
slow down, almost shut.
So a lot of times, if you're
having digestive problems,
it's because you're--
[SHALLOW GASP]
STEVE SISGOLD: --breathing
up here.
And the biology is telling
your digestive
system, shut down.
I've got to get up that tree.
Does that make sense?
Secondly, your heartbeat
starts to really race.
So you're pumping a lot of blood
to get up that tree.
And your muscles tighten
and tense so you
can get up that tree.
Now, just imagine that choice.
I want to give that
to you right now.
Every one of you, and myself,
have a choice.
Choice point-- am I breathing in
my lower abdomen, like yoga
teachers and martial artists?
You'll notice they're all
breathing down here.
Or am I breathing up here?
When I'm breathing up
here, I'm in my
sympathetic nervous system.
And that means my digestive
system's shutting down.
My heart's beating fast.
And my muscles are tense.
And often, that will correct
just the idea of having
tension, being exhausted
at the end of the day.
So just notice that that's a
choice between my breathing.
So right now, just notice, what
did you learn, anybody,
just about your breathing?
Like, is it easy to breathe
in or breathe out?
Are you breathing--
[BREATHES IN DEEPLY]
STEVE SISGOLD: --way
down in your belly
or up in your chest?
Are you not even aware,
usually, of
where your breath is?
Does anybody want to just
say anything you
noticed, just for--
in a minute?
Please, call it out.
AUDIENCE: So right when I
started paying attention to
it, I think I took
a deeper breath,
probably from lower down.
But if I'm not paying attention
to it, [INAUDIBLE].
STEVE SISGOLD: OK, so
basically-- thank you so much
because that's exactly it.
By paying attention to it, I
was taking in more oxygen,
which is going to oxygenate
my body.
I'm going to have better
circulation.
Cold hands, cold feet,
that comes from
breathing up in the chest.
And I'm going to take in more.
[BREATHES IN DEEPLY]
STEVE SISGOLD: So I'm going to
have more energy, more oxygen.
And I'm going to be in my
parasympathetic nervous system
where I can be relaxed.
I can make better decisions.
It's kind of like a wider view
than when we're tense.
So I just wanted to start with
that and show you this.
And here's two guys, if you
can see it, who are
absolutely, the title of the
speech, staying resilient and
engaged in one purpose.
Now, the reason I show you
that-- if you can't see it,
they're two cavemen.
I tell you what, they're not
thinking about anything that's
happening before.
They're not thinking about
what happened at
the breakfast table.
They're not thinking
about later.
They're totally engaged.
And they're what's called
"intrasomatic." We used to be
intrasomatic.
We used to-- everything was
like smell, taste, touch.
I have a little granddaughter.
Everything's feel, right?
But then, we forget.
So I just want to show you
the two kinds of ways.
I think it's great that we're
more than just cognitive, and
not just intrasomatic and
touching, and that we have
such great technologies.
But at the same time, that
imbalance of where we're
always outside and not feeling
can take us into stress, and
can lower our immunity
system, and can get
us to be less creative.
So just take that in
for a minute that
there's always two choices.
One is intrasomatic, where
you're using your senses.
Somebody gives you a problem
or a question, you can go
right to your mind.
Or you can take a moment--
[BREATHES IN DEEPLY]
STEVE SISGOLD: --take that
deep breath, and start to
really listen.
And I guarantee you'll get
better answers, even more
answers, more solutions,
more options.
Then, we became extrasomatic.
We started to write.
And we started to go external.
So basically, that's a fortune
cookie saying, I can't give
you any information.
And then, we became really
extrasomatic, where, pretty
much, we were looking outside
for everything, OK?
So we're going to be working,
today, on how to, pretty much,
get more intrasomatic and
more into our body.
And of course, on top of that,
many of us were told it is not
OK to speak up.
It's not OK to say
what we need.
And as a result, a lot
of us became more
shut down and inside.
So I'm going to take you through
a little internal
assessment, if you would.
I've got some sheets here
we can hand out.
And we're just going to take a
little what I call a "BQ test"
together, OK?
And through that, my intention
is that each of you will have
a little more awareness.
And just ask these questions
with no judgment, just
observation.
And we'll go through
them together.
And if it's OK, Rachel,
I'm going to need one.
I just realized that.
So I can go through it together
with everybody.
And you can share.
Or I'll be glad to make sure
that Rachel gives you whatever
I hand out today if
you don't get one.
But we'll go through
it together.
So the first question to ask
yourself is, how often do I
notice the quality
of my breathing?
Like, right now, in this moment,
just ask yourself--
again, connecting with your
body intelligence--
is it shallow, deep. relaxed,
short, choppy?
Just aware.
Is it easier to breathe
in or out?
Sometimes, if people have
difficulty breathing in,
they're not able to
receive, just a--
[BREATHES IN DEEPLY]
STEVE SISGOLD: Take it in,
really take it in.
So take a deep breath from
your lower belly.
And just notice, with no
judgment, what's happening for
me right now?
Am I breathing easy?
The second question is, how
often do you consciously pause
from what you're doing just to
take a few deep breaths?
You'll notice a pitcher on the
pitcher's mound starting to
get sweaty, starting to have a
bad game, what is the first
thing you usually notice?
[BREATHES IN DEEPLY]
STEVE SISGOLD: They're trained
to take deep breaths.
The same thing with somebody
at the foul line playing
basketball.
They're trained to--
[BREATHES IN DEEPLY]
STEVE SISGOLD: --take a deep
breath, drop into your
parasympathetic nervous system,
let go of the stress--
[BREATHES OUT]
STEVE SISGOLD: --and come
back to that center.
This is just something that you
may or may not be doing.
But it's good to be aware of.
How often do you scan your
body to connect with how
you're feeling?
So right now, with no judgment,
just take a moment.
You can close your
eyes, or not.
And just take a scan of your
body, just to notice.
See, I'm noticing, since I've
said that, several people have
uncrossed their legs, sit up
straight, kind of make your
shoulders--
again, there's no judgment.
It's just an awareness that
throughout a whole workday,
how often am I taking a
moment to go, what's
happening in my body?
I could be giving a message
that's not getting across.
I could be slumping.
I could be holding onto my
computer, just anything that
we're aware of.
So just now, if you want--
you don't have to.
What did you just observe that
you weren't aware of a moment
ago, anybody, in your breathing,
or your body, or
scanning your body?
Does anybody want
to call it out?
AUDIENCE: Slouching.
STEVE SISGOLD: Thank you.
I was slouching, OK.
And again, no judgment.
But notice, as you go along and
we do the reboot, you'll
be able to correct that.
You'll be able to say,
I'm slouching.
That means I'm cutting
off my circulation.
I'm cutting off my energy.
I'm stressing myself.
I'm cutting off oxygen from
my innovative thinking.
And--
[BREATHES IN DEEPLY]
STEVE SISGOLD: --just taking a
deep breath, and unslouching,
and letting that go will bring
a new surge of energy to your
body and bring you back--
rebooting.
But we'll do more of that
in a little bit.
When you feel an uncomfortable
sensation, pain, or emotion in
your body, is your tendency to
tune into it or ignore it?
You don't have to
answer out loud.
But just take that in.
How often do I feel instinct,
I want to say something, I
have a good idea, that doesn't
feel right, I don't want to
go, but I'm going to say yes to
please that person, but my
whole body's screaming?
I have lots of stories
about that today.
Would you say you have a
body-friendly vocabulary?
This is very, very important.
A lot of us got in the habit
of saying, that's
a pain in my neck.
Oh, man, that's a real
pain in my--
and what happens is the message
is being sent down
through your nervous system
into your body.
So I had a client that had a
really tough ache from the top
of his head down the back of
his neck for six years.
And through breathing and some
awareness-- this is going to
sound simple.
But it is simple.
I said, what happened
six years ago?
As he was tuning in to, well,
this happened in a
relationship and different
things-- but you know, I
stopped paying my taxes
six years ago.
OK, yeah, what do you do every
time the thought comes up,
which is at least once a day,
that you're avoiding the IRS?
He says, oh, I have
this saying.
"I'm going to put it in
the back of my head."
Ah, well, if you study biology
again, he's sending a message
to the back of his head that
says, avoidance and pain.
And he's had pain
for six years.
Kind of a coincidence.
I made a simple suggestion.
Call the IRS.
I had an audit recently.
They're not going to bite.
Call the IRS.
Work out a plan with them.
He says, well, OK.
He calls the IRS, works out
a plan with them, pain
goes away that day.
So I just really want to invite
you to be aware of what
you say to your body.
I'm fat.
I'm ugly.
Oh, that person's a big pain.
Oh, that makes me sick.
Every time you do that, you're
sending a message into your
body that's going to
impact your body.
So I just really want to share
that because it's really
important to have a
body-friendly vocabulary and
not to let it out
on your body.
Are you aware of how congruent
your words and your body
language are?
I'm constantly looking at that,
being a speaker, that if
I'm telling you--
a good example.
I work with a chiropractor who
had a tremendous skill when
you got on his table, had the
best location, had all the
good stuff.
But some reason--
he came to me.
He said, I can't build
my business.
Well, let me tell you, when you
meet this guy, this is how
he greets you.
Now, who wants to go to a
chiropractor that's hunched
over like that?
So even though he's saying the
right things, his body
language-- that's what
I noticed in sales.
The body language wasn't
expressing health.
So I did something with him,
which we're going to do today.
I had him say out loud what he
wanted, just say it out loud
three times.
And he says, OK, I want
to have a succ--
[COUGH]
STEVE SISGOLD: Oh, boy, mm,
something in my throat.
I want to have a succ--
[COUGH]
STEVE SISGOLD: He could not get
the word "successful" out.
He was trying to say, I want to
have a successful practice.
But every time he said the word
"successful," something
in his body was speaking.
And he just ignored it.
So I had him tune into it, feel
into it, and go into it.
And I don't know if you ever
heard this term before, but he
had what's called a "cellular
memory." Have you
ever heard that term?
Or a "somatic recall?"
What that's saying is that
everything that ever happened
to us, from the womb
until today, lives
somewhere in ourselves.
This is being proven
by biologists.
Candace Pert, great book
on "Biology of
Belief," Bruce Lipton.
These people are proving, under
the microscope, that in
our body are memories.
So I have this guy breathe.
And I've done this
with many people.
And I let his body go into the
posture it wanted to, versus
trying to get out of it.
And as he said, I want to have a
successful practice, it kept
shrinking down like this.
And the more he said it and let
it happen, he shrunk down
to the point where he says,
god, I'm having a memory.
But I don't know if it's
conscious or I'm making it up.
And I said, that's OK.
What are you seeing?
And he says, I'm looking
out the window.
And I'm seeing every one of my
neighbors are getting new
bikes, and new toys, and new
skates for Christmas.
And I don't get anything.
OK, what do you think?
He said, well, I remember going
to my dad and my dad
saying, son, you don't
want any new things.
Money will make you sick.
You know how many
parents do that?
Inconvenient, it's a hassle.
Mommy, I'm really hot.
You're not hot.
Yeah, I'm real--
no, you're not.
What does that teach the kid?
What does that teach
a kid, anybody?
AUDIENCE: To hold back
their feelings?
STEVE SISGOLD: Suppress their
feelings, and, maybe I don't
know what I feel.
No kidding, two days ago, I
went to the hot springs.
I was just relaxing.
And I was sitting there.
And I watched--
it's crazy.
I watched a mother bring this
cucumber juice, which is great
for us at spas, to
the little girl.
And she said, you'll
love this.
It's like lemonade.
And the little girl drinks it.
And she says, eew, it's--
I don't like it.
Yeah, it's like lemonade.
And I'm thinking
to myself, hey,
lady, that's not lemonade.
I'm sorry.
But that's cucumber water.
So what happened?
The kid had to drink it and make
up for the mom, oh, yeah,
this is good.
It's like lemonade.
But two things came out
of that for me.
One is, wow, she can't even
have her own sense because
she's trained, like many of us,
that, no, this tastes like
this, or, no, it's
not hot in here.
And then, we start to lose that
trust in our instincts.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
And then, the second thing was
she now has to lower--
she has to now take lower
than what she deserves.
Now, she's already being trained
that even though you
don't like it, and even though
it doesn't taste like sugary
lemonade, I've got to
settle for this.
Does that make sense?
Those little messages that go
in that we teach each other.
So let's go on to, when
you make a decision--
and this is a big one--
whether it's a small or a
large one, do you take a
moment to consult how your body
feels before you decide?
Or do you just use your mind?
Because let me tell you, I have
made investments through
my mind because I thought
I should.
And they don't always work.
But then, there are times where
I would take a breath
and listen.
And I would feel something
in my body.
And rather than ignoring
it, I would touch that
spot and just listen.
And I'd go, oh, yeah, there's
that memory living in my body
that says this is not good.
Or there's something in
my instinct that says,
don't go with that.
And I'll promise you--
and I'm sure you'll
find this too--
that when we listen, when we
take that few moments to just
say-- and I've said that over
the phone to people.
Hey, I've got a great speaking
gig for you.
It's this, that, but that.
And I go--
I usually say, OK.
Or, I want to go the
movies tonight.
OK.
Now, I go, hey, let me call
you back in a few minutes.
And I listen.
And I feel into--
and you'll see, as we go along,
why that's important
because there are beliefs
in us that live in our
body from day one.
And they will influence us
in the decisions we make.
So my recommendation is, before
you make decisions,
before you jump into a project,
just take a moment,
and ask your body, and just
kind of listen to that
intelligence.
It's so intelligent when
we listen to it.
And on a scale of 1 to 10--
just curious--
how comfortable do you feel
in your own body?
And just notice that.
So before we go on, I'm going
to get ready for this next
slide, here.
We can't solve problems with
the same kind of thinking,
meaning if we have a problem,
and we're stuck in our head,
and we keep-- what
I call "spin"--
spinning that same thought,
we usually
don't get to the solution.
So here's, again, another
example of the body.
And this is not to brag, but
just to get the point across.
I had a rock star who had
written many, many songs and
is a tremendous songwriter.
He's got big hits, Grammys,
the whole works.
And he came to me.
He said, you know, I
have a contract.
And he had a tremendous
producer, Babyface.
And he said, I don't
know what happened.
But I'm blocked.
I cannot write.
No problem.
That's where the title "What's
Your Body Telling You?" comes,
because what happens is when we
go up here for the answer,
remember, this is what created
the block in the first place--
our thoughts.
Our thoughts sent a belief,
a feeling into our body.
And those beliefs stay
in our body.
I call them viral beliefs.
They're like viruses.
So this guy says the same thing,
which we're going to do
in a few moments.
I had him say what he wants.
And he says, I want
to write songs.
And I want to get
back on tour.
And, boy, things were happening
in his body.
Started sweating profusely.
Some anxiety was coming up.
Again, here's a guy who sits
at his piano and his guitar
and says, I've got to
write a new song.
I've got to write a new song.
I've got to write it because--
nothing's coming out.
Can you relate?
I mean, what's he doing?
He's stressing.
He's going through the
same belief systems.
And he's trying to get
it up here, which
is the problem anyway.
Dropping him into the lower
belly, breathing--
[BREATHES IN DEEPLY]
STEVE SISGOLD: --listening
to his body,
shaking out the tension.
All I did was said, what's
your body telling you?
Tell me what you want.
And as he did that--
what we usually do is we push
those emotions down.
We push that feeling down.
We'll do anything we have to,
whether it's a pizza, whether
it's a glass of wine, whether
it's a TV show.
We'll do anything we can
to get away from that
uncomfortable feeling.
And I do it as much
as anybody.
It's just training myself to go,
no, I'm going to listen.
So this guy listens
into his body.
And he starts to go, wow, I'm
starting to see how it was the
last time I had a hit and the
last time I went on tour.
And I said, well, what is
your body telling you?
He says, it's really
frightened.
Thank you.
Thanks for the truth.
What's going on in there?
Last time I was on tour, I
broke up with my wife.
OK, what else happened
on the last tour?
Because it was a great tour.
It was successful.
My brother and I started
getting into fights.
He got a little jealous.
And I'm not as close with him.
Hm, OK, and what
else happened?
Ah, my parents said, oh, you
think you're a big shot now.
So I want to ask you,
what viral belief
lives in his body?
I call it a viral because
it's just like a virus.
Every one of us have them.
I'll tell you mine
in a minute.
We have things that happened.
When things happened, the
first thing we did--
I guarantee it.
If I could videotape
any of you--
[GASP]
STEVE SISGOLD: --our instinct
is to hold our breath.
Remember, go right up
to that sympathetic.
The second thing we do is--
[SUCKS IN AIR]
STEVE SISGOLD: --we enroll our
body to hold onto that
uncomfortable feeling, whether
it's getting embarrassed in
the first grade, the first time
you made a talk, whether
it's somebody hurt you,
whether you got
frightened or shamed.
What we do is we--
[SUCKS IN AIR]
STEVE SISGOLD: --hold
our breath.
And we enroll our body
to hold onto those
uncomfortable feelings.
Does that make sense?
Can you relate to that?
So in his body were
these feelings.
And these feelings were--
his mind absolutely wanted
to write new music.
Our minds always
want to do it.
Something was blocking it.
It'll block us from creating
a great relationship.
It'll block us from going
to that event we know
we want to go to.
It'll block us from having
that creative
thought come through.
So what I did with him is I had
him say it several times
out loud, until that anxiety
came to the surface.
And he shook it out.
And then, we worked the rest of
the day-- because he came
up to my home.
We spent the rest of the day
embodying, getting in his body
that he could actually have
a different viral belief.
His viral belief was, if
I write new songs,
if I go out on tour--
in other words, if I create my
genius again, I'm going to
lose people, right?
Because that's what
the experience--
every one of you have done
things where you had an
experience, and it's
in your body.
And you might not think it.
But it might be living
somewhere inside.
So basically, we worked that
day on him getting into his
body, as I go on tour,
as I write new songs,
I'll make new friends.
People will stay in my life.
And eventually, he got it.
And that night, we
wrote a song.
I'm also a songwriter.
Secondly, he, that year,
had a Grammy.
And the next year, he sang
the song on the Oscars.
Again, that's just
one example.
But you'll see, since you have
my book, many examples of
people who just, when they
listened, and they went
inside, and really listened and
tuned in, they noticed,
wow, there's a belief in me.
I'm going to give you
my belief quickly.
And then, we're going to
do some work together.
So when I was a little older
than the last story--
maybe, I was about 10 or 11.
I was raised in Baltimore City
in a row house neighborhood
with everything in about
a four-block radius.
I had 23 cousins, five aunts and
uncles, and there was the
grocery store.
I never left the neighborhood.
We didn't know there was
an outside world.
As far as we were concerned,
this is life.
This is our life in
Baltimore City.
So one day, my cousins and
I got a bright idea.
And we decided that we wanted
to go out and see what the
world was like.
So we put our little
sweaters on.
And we walked up to what's
called Park Heights Avenue.
And we stuck our thumbs out.
We were like this--
big shots.
We were in our body.
We were happy.
We were excited.
And all of a sudden, a shiny,
black Chevrolet pulled up.
I had never seen anything
like it.
It had mag wheels.
And guys came out of it,
like more than six.
I had never seen guys like
this in my life.
I didn't know they existed.
They had greasy hair,
long, back.
They had black jackets.
And they were swinging chains.
I had never seen people
like this before.
They called us names and
started to beat on us.
And we ran home.
I want to ask you, what's
the viral belief that I
took in that day?
Because here's what I did.
[SUCKS IN AIR]
STEVE SISGOLD: And got
scared, and ran home.
Mom said, what's wrong?
Nothing, nothing.
It's OK.
It was great.
We had a good time.
What's the viral belief that I
picked up that day, anybody?
AUDIENCE: The world
is [INAUDIBLE].
STEVE SISGOLD: The
world's danger--
there you go.
That going out too
big is unsafe.
Well, guess what?
I have done a lot of
work on myself.
Obviously, you see
I'm up here.
I'm not shy.
I perform.
I speak.
I love it.
But one day, when my book came
out, I got a national TV show.
My mind was like, woo-hoo,
yeah, yeah, I can't wait.
I can't wait to get out there.
I'm sure you relate to this.
I'm sitting in the greenroom.
And they said, Steve Sisgold,
you're on in five minutes.
And I started sweating
profusely.
I had an anxiety--
I didn't even know what
an anxiety attack was.
Here I am--
[GASPING]
STEVE SISGOLD: And I went, what
the heck's going on here?
Because my mind kept saying,
I can't wait.
But somewhere in my
body, there was
something blocking me.
And I had five minutes.
So I ran to the restroom.
And I breathed.
And I listened.
And man, it was like I was back
on Park Heights Avenue,
and I was 11 years old,
hitchhiking, I swear.
I said, that's what it is.
So I had to kind of breathe
and relax myself, and tell
that inner memory that I'm going
to be safe and accepted.
I said it 20 times
in 3 minutes--
or in a minute.
I'm going to be safe,
accepted.
They're going to love me.
I'm going to be safe, accepted.
I'm OK.
[BREATHES IN DEEPLY]
[BREATHES OUT]
STEVE SISGOLD: My
body relaxed.
And I had a great interview.
But can you relate?
Can you relate that every one
of us, inside, had things
happen, whether it was
somebody betrayed us?
Next time we go on a date, our
body language is saying, yeah,
I want to be open.
I want to meet new people.
Really?
And we don't even realize that
what we're doing is we're
still thinking about
that last hurt.
You see what I mean?
So I want to invite you to do
something, if you would.
I want you to find a partner.
And if you'd be willing, just
stand opposite them.
Are you OK with that?
Do a little exercise?
OK, so stand opposite
a partner.
Take a moment here.
Just find somebody.
And we're not going
to chitchat.
We'll just go through
this quickly.
I want to keep to my time
agreement with you.
And just find a partner where
you're standing opposite them.
And for those of you
who are on remote,
just do it by yourself.
OK, does anybody not
have a partner?
OK, can you work in
a group of three?
Everybody OK with that?
Beautiful.
So, partner one, I just want to
ask you, for a moment, to
close your eyes and take a
moment, with your eyes closed,
partner one-- who's going
to be partner one?
OK, just invite you
to do this.
Might feel funny at first.
But you'll get something
from it, I promise.
Partner one, close your eyes
for a moment and just think
about something that you want
to create in your life.
Maybe it's something to
do with your job, your
department, a project.
Maybe it's about
a relationship.
Maybe it's about a dream
goal you've always had.
You want to bring your book
or something forward.
And, partner one, just notice in
your body what's happening
as you start to focus on what
it is that you want.
Just notice.
Like, did your heart start
beating faster?
Do you get butterflies?
Do you get tired?
Is your stomach tight?
Just notice.
And when you're ready, say out
loud to your partner two times
what it is that you want.
And then, we'll just
stop after that.
Just say, I want
to create this.
Or I want to have that.
I want to lose 10 pounds,
whatever it is.
Just try it.
Say what you want.
Right now, when I say three,
open your eyes and just say
your partner what it is
that you want, OK?
One, two, three, go for it.
Just say it out loud.
[CHATTERING]
STEVE SISGOLD: Say it again.
STEVE SISGOLD: OK,
now, thank you.
Thank you for doing
this with me.
Partner one, who just did
it, what did you notice?
Did you notice anything in your
body, any body language,
anything that happened as you
expressed your dream or your
project out loud, anybody?
Just call it out.
What did you notice,
partner ones?
AUDIENCE: I leaned back.
STEVE SISGOLD: You
leaned back.
OK, so when I said what I
wanted, I leaned back.
We're not going to
analyze that yet.
But it's just an awareness.
AUDIENCE: I smile a lot.
But I definitely was smiling.
STEVE SISGOLD: OK, that's
a good sign.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: I felt
my belly a lot.
But when my eyes were closed, I
felt I was breathing a lot.
And I kind of felt that
when I said it, too.
STEVE SISGOLD: Thank you.
So again, this is awareness for
you to take further after
today, to say, wow, is there
something like Steve or like
that rock star who
had the block?
Is it like the guy who couldn't
build his practice?
By the way, once he cleared that
belief that his father
taught him, that success will
make you sick-- that's what
his father taught him--
and he started affirming and
bringing into his body that
his success would actually make
him healthy, the guy's
business just quadrupled.
I've got it in writing.
It changes.
When we change in here, we
become the person that can
walk in a room and
manifest it.
If we're walking in, and our
mind wants it, but our body's
exuding another message,
that's the result
we're going to get.
So here's the best question.
Partner two, or B, what did
you notice, anybody?
What did you notice
in your partner?
Did you see anything?
Were they happy?
Did they give you--
I noticed when you said
what you wanted,
your hand went up--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
STEVE SISGOLD: --which could
be a good thing.
So what did you notice?
What did you notice?
AUDIENCE: He lit up
after he said it.
He got happy with it.
STEVE SISGOLD: Yeah, so when
my partner said what he
wanted, he lit up.
His hand went up in the air.
And he lit up.
But it could have been
like, I want a--
I want a--
I want a new relationship.
Or I want to write
a book this year.
Oh, but you know--
and that kind of stuff is
what we communicate.
Anybody else, either
partner A or B?
What did you notice?
What did you learn
from this simple
exercise so far, anybody?
AUDIENCE: When I turned
to thinking about it--
STEVE SISGOLD: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was definitely
focusing on what I'd seen.
I know it's like-- yeah, I was
kind of like doing this sort
of like levitating forward
thing [INAUDIBLE].
STEVE SISGOLD: Thank you.
So again, see this mind-body
connection we're having in the
room right now?
That was excellent.
When I thought about what
I wanted, something
started with my knees.
In other words, your body
is intelligent.
I can show you more slides.
But here's the basics
of those slides.
Dr. Paul Pearsall--
and we're going to do
another partner.
So just hang in.
Dr. Paul Pearsall, he found, as
a heart transplant doctor,
surgeon, that the recipient
who got the heart started
having feelings and thoughts
of the person
who died, even foods.
So imagine that.
The heart is intelligent.
You put a new person's heart,
and you start having different
behaviors, different
thoughts, and
different personality traits?
Wow, that tells me that
that heart's not
just pumping blood.
It holds onto memories,
feelings, betrayal.
Dr. Gershon, on the other hand--
and by the way, you can
have my PowerPoint, anybody
that wants to
see any of the slides.
Dr. Gershon, on the
other hand, has
done work in the gut.
The gut has the same buildup
as the brain.
The gut has the neurons,
the nervous system.
So when you get a gut instinct,
that's a brain
talking to you.
But we ignore it.
So just be aware of that.
And every one of you, today,
so far-- thank you for
participating--
I saw your bodies were
doing something
related to what you want.
And the more you go in and
listen to that, the more you
may be able to clear a block,
get an instinct, see what's
right or wrong.
So now, we're going to
switch partners.
Partner B, take a moment
and close your eyes.
And just notice what it is that
you would really love to
create in your life, something
to do with your position, your
work, something to do on a
personal level, family level,
exercise level.
Take a moment and say to
yourself, out loud--
I mean, inside, what it is
that you want to create.
And take a moment and notice,
what's happening
for me right now?
Just be aware of it.
Notice what's happening
in your body.
And now, partner B, when you're
ready, say out loud--
open your eyes.
Say out loud to your partner,
two times, what it is that you
want to create.
And just notice how
it impacts you.
[CHATTERING]
STEVE SISGOLD: OK, and then
we'll have partner
conversation in a moment.
So I noticed a few things.
I noticed, right away, somebody
said what they wanted.
And then, they went, whoa,
I was really scared.
That's great because
you notice.
You notice, I want that,
and I'm afraid.
There's a philosophy I have.
I want this, but I'm afraid.
The "but" absolutely drowns
out the desire every time.
I'm going to write a new-- oh,
we don't need any more books.
Oh, OK.
You know?
It's like I had to
get through that.
I'm going to go out and sing.
[MUTTERS]
STEVE SISGOLD: So all these
beliefs that we were taught
live in our body.
And also, what'll happen is
we'll say, I want this.
And then, our body will give us
a signal like fear or some
parent who told us we couldn't
do it, and we just
shut down the idea.
But imagine this.
I used to live on Maui.
And people would come.
And they'd want to dive off
of this famous spot.
And they'd get up there.
And they'd be ready to dive.
And they would freeze.
And I would say, OK,
you're at a choice.
You can climb down, because
it's going to be easy.
[SIGH]
STEVE SISGOLD: I don't have
to go through it.
And then, you're going to fly
home feeling like heck.
Blech, I should have done it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
STEVE SISGOLD: Huh?
AUDIENCE: Was it Black
Rock on Maui?
STEVE SISGOLD: Um.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
STEVE SISGOLD: Exactly.
Tuned in.
The Black Rock-- she jumped.
So here's what I told them.
You can have both.
You can have your desire
and your belief.
You can say, I want to
jump, but I'm afraid.
And change it to, I'm going
to jump anyway.
So, I want to jump,
and I'm afraid.
And then, once you do that,
you're going to jump.
So this is how it goes every day
with every one of us, that
in every moment it's a choice.
[GASP]
STEVE SISGOLD: My
fear came up.
Should I just shut it down?
I see some nods.
That's good because you know.
[GASP]
STEVE SISGOLD: I want to
tell that new idea
to my project manager.
But, oh, they might
put it down.
They're--
and then, it goes back down.
So I want to encourage you to
feel it, and be able to
breathe through it, and say,
I'm going to do it anyway
because then you have
an opportunity.
So what did you notice, either
partner two in sharing it, or
partner one in watching it?
What did you notice, anybody?
One person said, oh, I
said my dream, and
I got really scared.
That's good because now you
know, if you go through that
fear, you'll have that dream.
If you let that fear overwhelm
you, it'll lock your body and
freeze you, and you won't.
So, anybody, call out what
either you noticed with
yourself or you noticed
with your partner.
Please.
AUDIENCE: Holding
their breath.
STEVE SISGOLD: Thank you.
So I was taught, as a kid, by my
mom, when you drive through
a tunnel, you hold your
breath, and your
dreams will come true.
It didn't work.
Whenever I hold my breath,
what I do is I get small.
I'm not oxygenated.
And my mind isn't thinking.
So that's a great awareness.
Thank you.
Really appreciate that because
it's just to notice that when
I say what I want--
[GASP]
STEVE SISGOLD: --the natural
thing is to hold your breath.
Why?
Because that's what we do.
When we get frightened, we get
right up to our sympathetic
nervous system.
And we hold our breath.
So that's just something
for you to do is, can
I say what I want--
[BREATHES IN DEEPLY]
STEVE SISGOLD: --and then
take a breath--
[BREATHES OUT]
STEVE SISGOLD: --and say it
again, and take a breath?
And then, eventually, it
becomes comfortable.
And my experience is,
you'll move forward.
So thank you, all of you,
for being courageous
enough to call out.
Anybody else want to call out
what you noticed, either
yourself or your partner?
Please.
AUDIENCE: I noticed that, for
Bill, when you had your eyes
closed, you were swaying
back and forth.
And then, when you said
what you wanted,
you got very settled.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was actually
more relaxed when I had my
eyes closed.
[INAUDIBLE].
STEVE SISGOLD: OK, so what we're
hearing is, more relaxed
when I was visioning, which
a lot of us do, right?
I want to be this.
I want to do that.
And then, to come out
and say it, what
happened in your body?
AUDIENCE: Well, I wasn't sure
how to say it concisely enough
to say it twice.
STEVE SISGOLD: Yeah, OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
what I was saying.
I think it was with the
delivery, maybe, I got a
little tense.
STEVE SISGOLD: So maybe, I got
a little tense about the
delivery, but again, just to
notice that and to be able to
push through it, versus getting
stuck, frozen, and
pushing that down.
Does that make sense?
OK, thank you.
I hope you got something
out of that exercise.
And I want to take it
a little further.
So again, I want to leave
a little room for--
[CHATTERING]
STEVE SISGOLD: --you
to ask questions.
[LAUGHTER]
STEVE SISGOLD: We're going to
practice this next exercise.
[CHATTERING]
STEVE SISGOLD: As we're handing
that out, here's the
philosophy behind it.
We repeat patterns.
Like, if I kept going out, and
the world kept looking scary
to me, that would
send a message.
It's not on the PowerPoint.
I'll just say, it's there.
And basically, I was
going to show you a
picture of the brain.
And basically, the brain has
these networks so that every
time you do something or say
something, that network is
sending a message.
When it says it over and
over repetitively,
it then gets locked.
The neuron gets locked.
And it becomes--
that whole neuron becomes
like a fixed wire.
And then, because of
repetitiveness, we then make
it an identity.
Does that make sense?
I have a thought that it's not
safe for me to go out, or
somebody said I'm not good
enough, a Little League coach,
or whoever it was.
And then, somebody else says I'm
not good enough, somebody
I'm dating or a parent.
And then, by the fifth or the
500th time that I say that,
what happens is it starts
to lock in.
And its fixed.
So it's not like something that
we're even in control of
because every time we get in a
similar situation, the brain
is immediately going to go,
you're in danger, even
though we're not.
Does that make sense?
It's a repetitive thing
that the brain and
neurotransmitter--
so our kind of work we're doing
today is busting that.
It's going to break it open.
Thank you.
I got it.
Thank you so much.
So basically, that's my little
viral belief graphic.
But if you want, you can get
this PowerPoint from me or
look into some of the
things I'm sharing.
And what I was sharing was these
neurotransmitters that
just keep coming in.
OK, we'll pass on it now.
But the point is it's a
picture of the brain.
And it's a guy named
Dr. Joe Dispenza.
And he has a book
about the brain.
And basically, what he's
showing, again, under the
microscope, is that if you're
repeating that over and over,
that I'm not good enough--
so be careful
what you say to yourself.
I'm not smart enough.
I'll never get that job.
The brain-- and here's
how it works.
So I was working with
an executive.
Guess what this executive
does?
This executive, whenever she
speaks, she gets a feedback
that says, what you have to
say is not important.
Can anybody relate
to that one?
Yeah, what I have to say
is not important.
Guess where it started?
She started working with me.
And we found it in the body.
When she was a little girl,
she would be at the dinner
table, and she would say
something that she thought was
a great thing.
And her brother always
interrupted her.
And her parents never
listened to her.
They listened to him.
So she started to get this
idea in her system.
What I have to say
is not important.
But guess what she does?
I call it "self-fulfilling
prophecies."
You're sitting with
her for an hour.
She doesn't say much.
We're just talking.
But then, you go to--
the curtain opens
for the movie.
And she says, hey, let me
tell you about my day.
Oh, not right now.
See, nobody thinks
I'm important.
She consistently sets up
situations to reinforce that
because it's in her brain
and in her body.
Does that make sense?
Am I getting across?
Every time she enters to do
something, as a leader or as a
manager, somehow, she'll
unconsciously say it at the
wrong time.
So somebody says, oh, god, we
only have one minute left.
And she'll go, darn, nobody
wants to hear
what I have to say.
So I had her really look at that
and change that behavior
because it was a neuro net in
her brain that was fixed that
kept setting it up.
That's why we-- sometimes you'll
say, I can't believe
that person's in the third
relationship that's abusive.
Why do they keep repeating it?
Because the first time it
happened, and the second
time-- and then, it starts to
become a pattern and a habit
that we believe in.
So my message, really, today is
that each one of us, as we
go through this rebooting
exercise, if you do this twice
a day, number one, it's going
to keep you really strong--
[BREATHES IN]
STEVE SISGOLD: --and
in your breath.
I went to a show down the street
called the Whole Life
Expo, or New Age Expo.
Have you ever heard of it?
They had this setup.
And I give you this to encourage
and inspire you
because it's changed my life.
They had a setup where you put
your hands in this machine.
And it tells you how much oxygen
you have in your body.
So of course, most people
were 40%, 43%, 28%.
And that's why they have cold
hands, cold feet, and they're
tired a lot--
not enough oxygen.
I was at 98%.
Now, why am I at 98%?
Because I'm doing this
all day long--
[BREATHES IN DEEPLY]
STEVE SISGOLD: --breathing with
people, helping people,
noticing my breath.
So I really want to encourage
you, when you leave here
today, to remember it's
always a choice.
Do I want to be in my lower
parasympathetic or up in my
sympathetic?
Because this one's going to shut
down my digestion, and
speed me up, and tire me out.
And I'm going to get tired.
Or this one's going to keep
me relaxed and solid.
And am I taking enough
deep breaths?
Am I aware of my
breathing, OK?
So looking at this exercise I
want to send you home with, I
want to encourage you
to just try this.
I did it before I started
talking to you today.
I do it any time I have a
presentation, I get on the
phone, just a good warmup.
And basically, the first
step is for you to
observe your breath.
So right at your desk, you can
take five minutes and just
notice, am I breathing?
Am I breathing full?
What's happening with me?
Secondly, you can
scan your body.
And you can notice-- and it's
important to say out loud,
like, wow, I'm noticing my
shoulders are up to my ears.
And just kind of drop your
shoulders and shake it out.
And then, just really take it
into breathing and scanning
your body at least once
or twice a day.
And then, coming back to, what
action do I need to take?
I might need to go outside.
I might need to make
that phone call.
I might need to shake it out of
my body because it can be
there all day if you don't.
And then, start to visualize
a calm ocean rhythm.
That's what happened in the
testing I showed you before
that the heart was beating
like this.
This is what's happening
with your heart.
But when you visualize your
heart like a wave, just to do
that starts to calm everything
down and put you back into
place of neutral.
Just like your computer,
you're rebooting.
And then, focus on what your
next intention is for the day.
And just focus on
that one thing.
Buddha taught--
here's what Buddha's teachings
were that I studied.
First thing is connect
with your breath.
Second thing is scan
your body and
notice what you're feeling.
And the third thing is to have
one focus, whether it's a
candle or a mantra.
This is the same thing, that
once or twice a day you can
reboot and re-energize.
So does anybody want
to comment on that?
How do you feel just thinking
about it, taking
it into your life?
And then, we'll have questions
and answers around that.
Anybody want to comment on
anything you learned today, or
noticing about your body
awareness or yourself?
Yeah, please.
RACHEL: You need a mic.
Hold on.
STEVE SISGOLD: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Are there any good
tricks in terms of making sure
it becomes a regular thing?
I know there are some computer
programs that'll interrupt
your day, morning and afternoon,
to stretch.
But is there something similar
to remind you to
just kind of reboot?
STEVE SISGOLD: Well, I'm glad
you're saying that because I'm
actually working on an app
that's going to remind you
twice a day to reboot.
I don't know of anything
like that.
But you know, what--
AUDIENCE: I mean, I could set
a reminder on my phone.
STEVE SISGOLD: I was going to
say, the little iPhones are
great because they remind
us of appointments.
So I used to put those kind of
appointments in my book.
Reboot.
Take an hour to write
your book.
So I would say that's
a great question.
And also, when I work with
companies, I'll have signs,
"Reboot." I just trained
an office in Las Vegas.
And all through the office now,
we have "Reboot," "Take a
Breath," "Say Positive Things to
Your Body." And it changes
the energy of the culture.
The whole room starts
to be more vibrant.
So thank you for-- that's
a great question.
AUDIENCE: One more question.
STEVE SISGOLD: Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: When you sort of say
these positive things to
yourself, does it matter if
you say them out loud?
Or can you say them
internally?
Or is there a difference between
the impacts there?
STEVE SISGOLD: That's great.
The question is, is the impact
different if you say it out
loud or inside?
Now, here's a couple
things on that.
Great question.
Number one is saying
those to myself,
inside, I noticed a change.
And I noticed an energy
difference.
So obviously, the more
we feed ourselves--
a lot of people saw "The
Secret." And they wondered,
well, I sit.
And I thought I was going to
get that Porsche because I
thought about it all day long.
And it didn't show up.
So it's good to think
positive thinking.
But I think to take
it into the body--
and that's why I say it
out loud when I can.
Like, ah, out loud,
I'm hearing it.
There's something that happens
in the brain through the ear.
And also, though, just the
vibration of saying it out
loud starts to move more energy
through the body, which
is why I had you do it
with each other.
Practicing saying it out loud
in front of somebody would
even bring more energy.
But thank you.
The positiveness is the idea
of not just saying
it, because I think--
I worked with a woman, Shakti
Gawain, "Creative
Visualizations." And she always
said, people thought
they could just read my book
and think about it, and it
would happen.
It's taking action.
And that's why I bring
the body into it.
What am I my noticing when I say
I want to create that new
idea in the office?
What am I noticing when I want
to go talk to my project
manager about something
that's off?
What am I my noticing here?
[BREATHES IN DEEPLY]
STEVE SISGOLD: Once we get that,
I think, then we can
walk in the room and attract
what we want and
exude what we want.
It makes a huge difference.
So thank you, great question.
A couple more questions.
RACHEL: We have time for
one more question.
STEVE SISGOLD: OK, thank you.
Anybody else have a question
before we wrap?
I really want to
thank you all.
AUDIENCE: Can you guys hear?
Can you guys hear
from the remote?
RACHEL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I thought I'd just--
I was just going to say, one,
there are related topics you
can study that teach
all this stuff.
One of them is tai chi.
Another one is singing.
Another one is dancing.
All of those have to do with
posture, and breathing, and
all of that.
And they'll help you
remember it.
STEVE SISGOLD: Thank
you-- qigong.
Any of it's good.
My main message today, really,
is just to leave here more
aware of, am I breathing?
Do I make decisions quickly
from my head?
Or am I going to take
a moment and listen?
And what would happen if I took
twice a day and took five
minutes to breathe, scan, shake
out that tension, set a
new intention, and then
walk in the meeting or
the room like that?
My experience is that you're
going to have a better result,
that you're going to attract and
get a better result from
what you need.
So thank you, Rachel, so much
for bringing me here today.
And thank you all.
You're welcome to email
me with questions
from my book or anything.
I'll be glad to answer them.
Thank you.